okay first of all I have a lot of things
to our dear friend and green mentor
professor richard a sure he has been our
friend for over 10 years and also he's
one of the reasons that we started off
about 10 years ago to become a student
entrepreneur so i'm going to run two
slides today one is a brief introduction
of the business that me and my husband
have it's called good way it's the
number one leading pooch platform in
china and after that i'm going to
introduce a little bit more about what i
am doing the end investment and
incubation part feel free to interact me
any time to throw your question i love
when audience up where the night we can
have questions okay so here we go so
this is a very brief history with
pictures about what we have been doing
in the past decade so we started off in
2005 right after the ASA summit in
Singapore so we have two major events
four aces and every year we have one in
April in Stanford and the other one
somewhere and in the summer in some
other Asian country or region so we
started our first start up after the
Singapore's amid back in September 2005
and on the left up this is the first
location that we can call office we
spent the first two years in a
residential building as most of the
entrepreneur do and we almost been that
period of time developing our product
which i'm going to introduce a little
bit later and on the downside that is my
dear husband and also my very close
partner in the whole startup business so
this is him speaking one of the local
events as to come as the as a
participant that's probably in 2007-2008
because he still looks younger than and
on the right here is a picture by New
York Times last year in September the
90s there was a major news for China
internet probably for the internet all
over the world Alibaba went listed again
in
my I see so that would probably be the
first time that the US citizens and you
know anywhere else notice that a Chinese
Internet company could be this big and
it could have all this potential so New
York time went to the city of Hangzhou
where we are building our business to do
a little bit of fuel study together a
vibration of what is this city is like
so in the interviewers interviewed me
and my husband and they feel that we
have a very interesting story so instead
of having Jack Ma on the front page me
and my husband was on the front page at
that day we re babo in public so the
title of the story is called millionaire
and risk-takers so you can still search
for that article online so here is a
picture of a family portrait that we
have in the company that we're currently
running is this is the office that we
have in the home Joe ok so where do we
start this is the first product that we
have so in a very fashionable way to say
that we started from intellect hardware
which is hard way to do it so this is a
mobile phone charger it can
automatically backup your contact list
to the charger when you charge your
phone using it and when you switch to
other phones it can automatically
rewrite your phone book to the new phone
so basically it's a very useful tool for
keeping and organizing your contacts
which is probably the most valuable
assets that you have found your phone so
we started his business in 2005 and we
work on the whole development process
for almost about two years which
actually exists what we had imagined in
the first place because remember we were
young and foolish then we thought that
we could finish the whole development
process in within two weeks and we just
sell the patent to some of the bigger
players over there and we get rich at
least that's how we thought it would be
but like most of the startup stories
they didn't work out that way so
we hit a lot of barriers we had a lot of
difficulty in the whole developing prep
process and also when we had the
products we didn't know how to market we
didn't know how to sell it because we're
still a bunch of students back then so i
think the lesson that we learned from
this product is that it always take much
much longer time than you expected to
turn a idea to a business first you need
to turn the idea into the product and
second you need to get the product to
the market and you need to develop your
market strategy you need to have
yourselves people you need to get the
sin out there and then you need to make
money but I think going through all this
process worse worthwhile because after
this we develop our second product which
is a online backup service that we
provided to China Mobile so at a time we
acted as a sourcing company it didn't
sound that cool but it helped us to make
some money and by the way the first
product we made the indian store is that
we sorted to buy do at 2010 so it was a
okay ending it was not where we have
dreamed up but we did make our first
bucket of gold out of that so this is a
second product as you can see it's a
software and we started this business at
2008 that's almost the dung of what we
called mobile internet area so I phone
was already there but there were now so
many smartphone work around people was
switching from the featured phones to
the smartphones so there was a real need
to get all the contacts information
managed uncloudy on the website so this
is what we were providing to china
mobile and they paid us a little bit of
money to do this so a was a ok business
it helped us make some profit but we
didn't think that it's what we wanted to
do we didn't want to stop there so this
is the third product and which might be
so far the
the biggest innovation that we had well
except from good way so this is a third
product at the at the end of year 2009
remember at that time iphone 4 was
already in the market everybody was
switching to the smartphones so at that
time we were thinking while we were
observing the China market we saw that
there would be a great opportunity for a
great instant messager company to have
their software over there on every from
people would be switching from SMS to
the instant messager everybody would be
using this instead of sending texts so
we started there we started even earlier
than kik and then we chat then lined and
all the other apps we started at the end
of 2009 and I want to develop this very
great instant messager we call a good
scene well in Chinese means like
individual messaging because she is the
name of the products so we did this but
unfortunately we didn't make it to the
end of course everyone is using which
head now I'm sure most of you most of
you will have a witch head account so we
did that and for a while I remember for
about 9 or 10 months we did have more
users than which had but we we lost the
battle around the end of 2011 actually
we successfully raised a round of a
round funding at the beginning of 2011
and we did the largest recruit we did
largest recruitment and the promotion we
have ever done because we have all this
VC money right now we can employ other
people we can throughout the attachment
in the market but it was still nothing
compared to what pens ink and it can do
at that time they deploy about like
hundreds maybe even thousands of
Engineers to put on that crew product
they have called which head and so we
have we have about 20 million users a
top like a peek for this product but
approaching the end of 2011 we feel that
this product is already gone there's no
way that we can compete with Tenzin in
the consumer market so we switch to the
last one so this is a very brief history
about the company which is on my name
card it's called Cushing so Cushing
interactive was founded at summer of
2010 and now we have two major offices
in Hangzhou and Beijing and right now we
have over 140 employees in our team
which from a different internet company
such as I do Google IBM Cisco tenzin at
all that we have close to round of
funding by Sprint last year I right now
these are few of our major clients maybe
some of you are quite familiar with all
this Chinese company we have Sina Weibo
which is a China equivalent of Twitter
we have mochi weather which is a weather
app we have pptv which is a peer-to-peer
streaming video application and we have
chunar which is a little bit like
booking which is a little bit like
booking orcas are dot-com and we have
all these different apps so these are
all our customers so there is a bit of
data about what we do we are actually
not an app company there is not an app
called good way we are a p.2d company
business to developer we provide the
software developed kit to application
developers providing them with this push
notification function or ability so what
what they do is that we give them the
SDK and they and they be packaged with
in there a PP and they will also have a
user account on our platform and then
their their app can have the ability to
push the message to their users at any
time any content or information as a
wish so here
here are a few numbers that we have
right now we have over in China we have
over 900 individual mobile phones and
hazards that's about over ninety percent
of the total smartphone market and
that's about one hundred percent of the
android phone market and we have a
communic we have accumulated users of
four billion from all the different apps
that we are now serving so if you do the
math on every android phone that has our
sdk average they would have five or six
of them because keeping people are using
multiple apps what we do is that we help
them deploy and sending messages and
every day we will be send 1.5 billion
messages to all the mobile phones around
china and on a good day I know you're
very familiar with the black friday in
the US and some of you may have heard
there is a similar black friday in China
which is called the November the 11th
the singles day so on that day all the
big b2c e-commerce website will do the
promotion and people will get crazy
shopping so on the China Black Friday
last year we sent three billion messages
within 24 hours to all the mobile phone
users inside of China any questions
about that okay people are quite
shocking with the numbers don't worry
we'll get to we'll get to technology
details if any one of you is restricted
so um at the end of last month we have a
conference called jimick it's a global
mobile Internet conference which is the
highest level of industry get together
inside of China for mobile Internet we
host our own panel we host our own
meeting and we announced this very new
and very cool product which is called
good twist three-point oh and you may
ask ok this is three-point mo so what is
one point 0 and 2 point 0 so we started
off as
a simple technology provider at point at
one point oh we just do our push
technology and at a two point oh we
provide the extra storage which we call
the value-added service so we provide
some basic an electric tools which are
online so as the app developer you can
watch you know how well you're doing and
we will give you a battery some
suggestion how to deploy and how to use
the push because it's really double
sewer technology if you do not use it
right people will get rid of you because
if you push too many messages per day
people will get annoyed so back to the
good way through point O we provide a
location-based a kind of push service to
all the different apps so apps can use
this to promote themselves to get better
user activity or they can use this as a
tool for mobile advertisement because as
I understand forty percent of the mobile
internet advertisement income of
Facebook come from all kinds of
different attachment of apps today apps
through a lot of money this were a lot
of bugs to promote themselves so we want
to get some benefit out of that so how
do they do for example if we said
today's venue as a geometric fencing as
a geometric fenced area everybody who is
carrying an android phone working to
this area will get some notification say
hey there is a very cool event which
will be going here in about ten minutes
and perhaps it can even be
differentiated because we have a big
data on our platform so we wouldn't be
sending everybody the same information
we would send a customer information
that we know would interest you most so
if we were in a shopping mall and you
guys come here perhaps some of you would
want to go shop some of you would want
to see a movie and some of you would
just want to have afternoon tea with
friends if you are already user and we
have established your User Profile we
will able to
somehow assume that there is a bigger
chance that you will do this kind of
activity and we will send the relevant
push to you rather than sending
everybody the same message okay here's a
part of work when i brag about my
company but actually we are here to
check out some of the cool companies and
celebrators and incubators we have been
plug and play and google and facebook
today so i understand this is nothing
compared to what Silicon Valley has but
we're still very proud of it because we
are actually a very very local company
when I say local that means me and my
husband we have never systematically
studied abroad so that was what they
call to be so we are still trying to
learn from what's best out there so this
is where we work we have a very cool
balcony and as you see we decorate our
company in a very high-tech very Silicon
Valley way I'm hoping it could be very
Silicon Valley and we have the football
on the table we have all kinds of cool
gaming for the boys so what we do is
that we try to provide our engineers we
try to provide with our employees the
best environment that they can have when
they work okay and because this used to
be a recruitment talk so I'm going to
talk a little bit about the welfare well
people are complaining nowadays it is
very hard to recruit talents for
startups in China because a you have to
compete with by do Tenzin and Alibaba on
the salary level which is actually quite
high but well it's relatively low
compared to everybody else's earning the
Silicon Valley but it's still quite high
compared to the other jobs inside of
China and also right now when we are
hiring we are hearing people in their
twenties what we call in China jolene ho
the people who were born in the 90s they
are different from any generation within
China recent history I think that
they're more like their peers in the
u.s. they
their own ideas and they do not they do
not like to be confined to any candle
you know perhaps and theoretic rules and
they wanted to be treated very good even
if you are a start-up so what we provide
is that we organize monthly birthday
parties for our employees and we have
yoga classes every Tuesday and every
Thursday i personally like them very
much and we have the company tour and
every year at least twice and we have
fruits and we have all kinds of perks
for our employees in the company and
wednesday i'm very proud of is that we
have weekly study i would not call it a
study meeting my husband caught it can I
see I don't think that's a word let's
just call it boss time so basically
every Monday we have a CEO or higher
management to come to the stand and they
just talk to everybody especially the
new employees about a little bit about
our history a little bit bit about what
they're doing and a little bit about
what we should be doing for the company
so I think the idea originated from the
TGF over here in company like Google and
others so in that way the new employee
can have a quick glimpse of the 10-year
history of this company all or what is
the so-called cooperation culture and
also we organized by week reading
parties and seminars are about our
industry are sometimes not so closely
related to mobile Internet it could be
anything cool anything related to
technology so I think in that way we
will have this very good environment for
people to be motivated to be inspired to
learn something new okay that's about it
so this is a very brief introduction
maybe not so brief about about the
company of a good way which belong to me
and my husband any questions here you go
ah like we have so many users and we
want to push something that's what most
relevant to that person yeah how do you
do personalization yeah that's a very
good question oh so because we have
naturally a big data platform right so
we know let's just say we know a lot
about our users because it's used it's
USA it's very sensitive I don't wanna
get myself in trouble but we know a lot
of about our users we do a thing called
user profiling right it's basically I
think it's basically the same messer the
same strategy that Facebook and Twitter
and some other social networking stuff
they have basically they can tell you
know where you're from and what you do
and even your average income level or
where you are and we know the similar
stuff so we have your User Profile we do
not necessarily need to know who you are
but we want to know your consumer
behavior because that's what's most
relevant that's most useful for us so
once we have that and then remember that
we have the channel to reach you at any
time you get connected to the internet
so we are able to put difference we are
able to put different customers
information directly to you once you get
online you do not have to open your app
because it's a push thing once you get
online will be able to reach you and we
can give the message to you okay over
there so fast enough of your revenue
model yeah so if I understand across
okay so you cannot sell your sub some
sort of API or the software to apps and
they use your product yep thing to do
how do you think program in my name yeah
again very good question so currently
actually we have two major business
model one is what we call the freemium
the freemium so for apps with
milling or less users we let them just
use our service for free because there
are small apps they may not be welding
or they may not be able to pay money so
we just let them use that for free and
for apps with 5 million and up users we
charge them / Mouse according to the
level of their concurrent users so it's
like the bigger you are the more you pay
because just like water or electricity
bill right I think that that is fair and
on top of that remember from good to two
point O we provide some basic analytic
tools so that is called value-added
service so for that part we also charge
our users some money and apart from this
one there's this mobile advertisement
I'm talking about so for that it's just
similar like Google or Facebook or any
other company who does attract men over
there we take a certain percentage of
the whole revenue from the attachment we
split the revenue with the alp owners
okay over there so you see one day you
send three messages yeah how many
perhaps for those streaming well
actually they were a member on that I
think we have about we have about 500 k
we have about 500 k applications but the
roux is actually i think the roux is not
228 the roux is actually 129 in the word
of ab click application so if you count
the number of apps less than ten percent
of the apps actually have over ninety
percent of the volume of the user
because the big app can be very big
right and most of the smaller ones they
have you know relatively small number of
users say about 1 or 2 2 million at tops
so actually is not the number of apps
account is can you have all the bigger
ones the big oversized sina weibo are
emoji weather
npp TV and more more which recently
calluses yeah the bigger website I'm
thinking the bigger one should be 500
million users and up that's that's how
we define the bigger ones yes so after
your service kind of got pushed off the
board by we chat yeah okay things that
was not a good ending to that particular
project yeah did that make it more
difficult to get funding for the next
thing well actually the story is very
interesting since you mentioned we got
we went out to raise our first round and
at the end of at the end of 2010 so if
you remember the company actually
established at July of 2010 right so we
started because we have a little bit of
pocket money by selling our first
product to my do so we just went ahead
and set the company and then we started
our a round of funding we start to raise
the funding at the end of 2010 and we
got our term sheet and the document
signed at the beginning of 2011's and
because in China it is too difficult to
get US dollar money you know transport
and change to rmb and you know have to
build all the structures and VI ease and
blah blah blah blah so the very
interesting is that we have already
signed the documents and we know we have
money we have about several millions of
US dollars we know we have the money but
we cannot which we're over we cannot get
our hands on it and actually before the
first around the money even get to our
bank account in the form of RMB we
already know the business is not working
yeah and we decided to change well
luckily I mean we wind over the support
from the board because they can decide
that you know we just call it off we
don't we don't care we would not want to
buy your story but luckily we got them
on board
we switch to the new stuff and also it's
its lucky for us because we decide to
pivot early we had a meeting with the
other one of the other major players I
don't know if you guys still remember
them it's called talk box top box was
pretty huge at that time when all the
you know kick and a messenger came out
and it was a Hong Kong company so we met
with them in San Francisco about it two
days ago so this stick to their idea
still so they did the instant messenger
to 2013 so that's two years later than
we decided to pivot so I think one thing
is that luckily enough we made a quick
decision and we got the board to support
us so you pivoted and were able to use
the series yeah we're pivoting I knew
that sir is a round of money to do that
and when we did a little bit actually
there were the series a round the
founding was in 2011 and we raised our
beer and the founding at the beginning
of 2014 so that's already three years
later and we have already done a lot by
then I remember at that time when we
were raising money for Sirius B we have
already got five million five hundred
million accumulated user from all the
apps and we were having like three
milling we were having like 300 million
unique phone sets so we were about like
half or a little bit less than half the
market size we are having now so we have
already proved ourselves to some extent
so it was relatively easy for us to
raise money the market was also high in
a moment but we did it yeah I've got one
other follow-up question on that yeah
was there anything you learned
especially by experiencing that need to
pivot haha well well it's a is always a
painful process but there are a lot of
sense to be learned well frankly
speaking we have pivoted at least three
times if you're counting all the major
business event and there they were even
side projects at
time to mention today we were doing a
little bit of this and a little bit of
that so the saying is that first of all
you have to always keep an eye on your
competitor and then you need to decide
especially the CEO need to decide when
is the time to call it off because
everybody can be giving you all
different opinions and feedbacks about
you know whether this is going anywhere
I was going nowhere but the CEO he or
she has to make up their minds and once
they do you never look back some some of
my friends do you know said to me that
if you guys stick to good we probably be
a different story I think I probably be
different but you cannot repeat history
yeah so first of all you keep an eye on
your competitor keep an eye on the
market and then you make the decision
and second um do everything to win the
over the support of your investors
because one of the reason a lot of
company didn't succeed succeed in
pivoting is that the lost the trust of
investor because you told them a good
story right and they give you money and
suddenly you tell them hey I don't want
to do this or I cannot do this anymore I
have to switch to the others in the
first question they're going to ask is
why right so you better you better have
a good story and a certain is that it's
it's especially important it's crucial
to have the support of your core team
because we were a small company for a
very long time period we started from we
started from five people and three of
them were aces members at that time and
for a quite long time probably till the
end of 2009 for quite a long time we
were never more than 30 people we were
very small team and then suddenly we
were we got the first round of founding
we got around the founding we grow so
quickly we almost hit 200 at one point
so it was like every day we were hiring
and we were recruiting so I am curious
how you were able to grow so fast
and take ninety percent of the smart
phones you know to manage to get your
platform how to do that so fast so
recruiting was not easy and especially
when we were pivoting we actually had to
cut the cause and fire most of them so
it was like 20 to 30 for several years
and then boom sadly 200 and then back to
60 so at the whole process you need to
know which are the people that you are
not going to lose whatsoever you want to
keep them but at the same time you need
to according to the book written by reid
hoffman alliance let the employees that
that you laid off leave the company with
integrity right you you have laid the
mouth right you don't need to hurt them
again so when we were firing people at
that time actually it was a good time
for the whole mobile internet so
companies are lining up at our door to
get our employees so I would say most of
the employee if not all of them have
already have some job offer before you
know we give them the goodbye so at
least that's the one thing that I think
we did right so answering your question
how will be able to grow in so fast
actually after that cut back it takes it
took us about another two years to grow
to the size so by the end of last year
by the end of 2014 we were still a
company with less than 100 people but if
anything I would have expected that at
that point somebody like Ali Baba or
maybe baidu would have had the big data
analysts inside their company and we've
really been able to get into this yes
they have actually all the three big
company the Baidu Alibaba and Tenzin
they have either got their in-house team
or they acquire some other company to do
this but I'm technology level and a
market level they were not half as good
as what we are doing because it is a
very is a very clear business especially
for the bigger ones people want to cut
costs and people want to have a stable
and they want to have a good service
and for those big companies this is
still a too early and not so important
sector for them they want to have a
company they want to have a team in this
but they're now going to pay too much
attention on this we have unless I see
you starting to get real business yeah
well we have already started to get real
real once we get into this market in
2012 so our first and our first major
client was in that way boy so Sinha
helped us a lot and so from that time
they were they were be a tease they were
the big companies they were also other
startup competitors but gradually they
just fade out either because they cannot
do the technology because it's not easy
and you have to be able to do it with
millions or tens of millions or for us
about three hundred millions of users
are online at any time of the day you
have to be able to do that otherwise
it's just a lab concept that you can do
this is not a real product and also I
would say all the employees in our
company they have very good service
spirit we would say that we treat our
clients with respect a lot of big
companies are very snobbish they don't
want to deal with you unless you can pay
the real money right but we started out
from small so we understand the need and
the demand of this some individual or
some small startups so we we would love
to be there with them from the beginning
there's an example of another very
successful startup that set by George on
university alumni it's called in it's
like a Chinese equivalent of Instagram
because we cannot use Instagram in China
as a lot of other cool products so they
started summer last year and we signed
them the first mouse they release their
product and they hit one mini users
within the first mouse and then there's
five million there's ten and right now
they have about 30 million users and
they're very happy with our service
and I think in this industry the word of
mouth is very important especially from
the big and the success once the hot
ones in the market because they are
going to go around you know talk about
how successful and how to be this
success when people will be asking what
kind of user tools that you are using
write a recommendation from this kind of
players could be very valuable yeah yeah
okay I understand there's more and and
there is a question from that gentleman
yes stealing challenges from ebay is
your platform whole scheme yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah that's a very good
question i'm suspecting that you are a
engineer haha are you okay so as i
mentioned our first client and our first
major one is sina weibo it's a China
equivalent of Twitter they have now
about 800 million users one of the
bigger ones so at the beginning of 2012
that was a time when Weibo was growing
most fast it was like tens of millions
of user per month kind of gross so we we
started we started wisdom at the
beginning of 2012 and we served them
only for about six months because we
want to do it in this way and we did it
for free leave later we were able to
clear some money from it but we did it
for six months with them only and we did
it for free because we want them to have
the patience to play and grow with us
because we know our servers are going to
crash and it's a it's a huge challenge
because in this kind of developer
service unless you have experienced tens
of millions a level of conquering the
user you do not call yourself that you
have a product or a business right
because that would be only laboratory
level so I think Cena did us a favor by
allowing us to crash and burn so many
times within the first six months
because we charge them nothing right so
they cannot complain too much so that's
on the technology side and on the
business side
our sales and marketing people they were
waiting they were waiting till the
service was a little bit more stable but
they were constantly can't connecting to
every other big big ones in the market
seeing that hey we are now are
cooperating with Xena and we are having
some very good news of course we
wouldn't tell them that our service
crash and burn but where we will say
that and we'll say I know you are very
successful suspicious about our service
right now you wouldn't want to be the
first one to eat a crab but if Cena is
very happy with us would you like to be
our second customer so the salespeople
was already go around and circling
around to get some buyers attentions and
after six months we feel is it was a
time it was ready to go time so we just
go to the market and we grab the big
ones and we start to charge money at
that time and I the public provider we
have our own data centers but we still
need to have the computer clusters from
the china telecom mobile and they're
there like three of them yeah so we have
the public part but we we build our own
service with we build our own server
because on that part is also a great
technology advantage that we have our
average one server can only show there
about tens of thousands of people or one
hundred of thousand people like most but
we can have more than 5 million
concurrently user per server so that is
that that is our one secret source of
that so we build our own server ok I
think that's good and there's more
action I do you have a question actually
I think that ok we need to sleep depends
on how you want to use the time we've
got about 30 flow maybe we can have a
more question about this later and we
can switch to the incubation and enjoy
investment part so this is the newly
opened incubator in the city of Hangzhou
we call it be wet
can anybody guess what the logo means
any thoughts it isn't familiar yeah so
maybe on the right side is more familiar
this stuff san francisco bay it's a san
francisco bay and that is hans obey
hahaha so we call south bay west because
here is bay area and how do we have very
beautiful westlake as professor daniel
said so we want to be a bridge of local
entrepreneurs with the international
market with a bigger world so this is
our logo it's too cause okay um here a
few more bragging about myself so this
is a New York Times newspaper just to
prove what I said was true and in the
middle there's an article about me in
the whoosh elbow channel mr. Wu shall
bow is one of the most successful
financial writers inside of China he's
now currently visiting Bay Area and on
the right side this is the opening music
festival for the whole dream town and I
was sitting and I was MC for that night
that's a little bit of how they on my
own I'm a crazy karaoke fan okay so here
are a few pictures of our Bay West
accelerator so as you can see it's very
new you can see there are two levels and
on the top there is the glass conference
room actually do feel glass conference
rooms and yeah this is a this is a
ground floor we have all the open space
as a co-working space for the startups
and this is the stairs and this is our
opening ceremony for the bigger size you
can see I was wearing the same dress it
was before the day that I left for the
Bay Area so
I opened it I come here on the maid nice
I open it on made eight yeah just one
day before I came here so the gentleman
standing next to me is my husband even
he cute okay I'm going to just put it
out here so people can read so this is a
joint effort of entrepreneurs and
venture capital so the founders and
shareholders of baybez including
entrepreneurs like me and my husband and
also local venture capital early-stage
capital like lien and later stage
capital and science parks there is a
very famous science park called foodie
Science Park which were currently the
good big company is currently in so they
are also the shareholder and here are a
few introduction off well it's actually
just one sentence on my husband's family
so he is the serial entrepreneur and
it's very actively involved in the local
startup community actually he is also
actively involved in the international
startup community as we are speaking
right now he is traveling with the head
of our province in Israel he's going to
visit a few incubators and cool
technology startups over there okay so
here are more introduction about us so
the founders including my husband and I
and there's also a coup architect called
Ram how he is the winner of Forbes
magazine 30 under 30 business elites so
hey easy architect himself but he says
he's very enthusiastic about helping
startups in the internet space and he
also helped design our good way office
in Hangzhou and he's also a close friend
we helped to ensure
we helped him to get his girl friend and
soon-to-be wife and for this incubator
our advisors include dearest professor
from Stanford University and former
chairman mr. golden Davidson from
Fenwick and west and also professor
which are both from management school
Joe John University and we are also
organizing a regularity international
startup competition Silicon Valley and
Cambridge exchange so I am here we are
going to send another team to Cambridge
in a coming september-october because as
we all know Cambridge is also heart of
entrepreneurship inside of Europe so
that is also a very cool place to visit
one purpose of this trip apart from
giving this speech and seminar in
Stanford is also getting to know and get
in touch with more of the local
incubator so we have visited Berkeley
sky deck we have visited plug in place
and we're also going to meet 500 startup
and perhaps why see if they have us and
we want to establish this kind of
cooperation with the local incubator it
could be a one-week exchange trip and it
could be a three-month exchange
co-working space it could be helping a
startup from Silicon Valley to build
their China branches to help them to do
a little bit of recruitment to help them
to do a little bit of market study if
they want to have a China focus
somewhere in the future and here is part
of we are very proud of I understand
that in Silicon Valley the most
successful kind of early stage
investment are caught the founders funds
basically they are the people who are
entrepreneurs themselves and they also
act as enjoy investor and they have the
experience from the industry they are
not too far from the battlefield so this
is what we want to do an adjust what
we're doing we believe coach is
more important than mentor because you
have to understand in China right now be
an entrepreneur is a very hips in the
government is all about you know
everybody should go out and be
entrepreneur and you should all be your
own startup and there are a lot of
startup mentors usually people very big
and successful but from our perspective
I remember there were a article from
TechCrunch saying that startup should
have people who have been on the same
road but two to five years earlier than
you to be your helping hand rather than
those really big and successful and rich
people maybe they already too far away
from the battlefield so in my
understanding I cement or being a
start-up mentors like you know standing
on a high horse is saying everybody you
should charge but if you die out there
you die out there it's not there are
their fault but being a coach meaning
that your welfare or your benefit is
closely related to the students that you
have right and also because from us we
also enjoy investor we invest our real
money inside them and we want them to be
successful and we want to help them
perhaps on a daily basis if we can so we
want to provide them everything they
need some human resource product sales
and marketing financing public relations
and government relations and all that
because we have been on this road 10
years ago we were is we were still down
to 4 News and right now we ask to
entrepreneurs we're not far away from
the market we understand what is going
on we see the opportunity and the
challenges over there so we would love
to share our experience and network and
passion I'm preserve Lee with them so we
have now invested about we have already
closed 12 investment but we have about
three to five in the process so we have
10 plus almost 20 portfolio companies
all of them are very early stage mobile
internet startups
this is one of my earliest i vs 0 is
working on a mobile gaming company we
invested them in 2011 they were our
first portfolio and now so is helping me
with some of the management after we
invested them because we consider that
to be a very important part and also
learning from by sea because being a
huge alumni network I think one thing
you should always utilize is that to let
young entrepreneurs to educate
themselves right educate and network
future leaders in business and
technology that's what is in safe so
apart from what we can give what the
partners of the family can give the
young entrepreneurs we encourage them to
hold regular seminars you know
discussions and meetings with each other
or just go out and have a glass of beers
and talk about their business because it
is really helpful and they themselves
may understand the market even more than
we do because they are right now
fighting in it so here are a few are
snapshots of what we do so this is our
CTO of good way he is giving out speech
about technology and also about how to
fill in China not how to win because he
used to work for MS in China as a chief
architect and the company fell apart
after he left well failure can be very
valuable lessons and on the down right
side there is the session about IP
protection and how to write or how to
write your own patent well everybody is
saying that in China we don't have a P
protection but that is not true I
encourage my CEOs to write their own
patent to apply their own trademarks
because apart from saving thousands R&B
it's good education because those agents
out there they would not be able to
enter the business like you do and you
should do that yourself at least you
should do the first three to five
yourself and once you get the drill you
can you know delegate somebody else
to do it but I always encourage them to
read the patents themselves it's great
exercise so here are part of what we do
as the bay west exchange as an
international exchange we think to know
the bigger word is the first step to
change the bigger world so we believe in
educating our young entrepreneurs we
want them to have the experience that we
have from Stanford from MIT from Harvard
from canvas from all the top university
from other harbin the heart of
innovation so right now we have already
established some working relationship or
with the incubator right here we have a
cooperation program with you for 8 with
hina by trend these are just the
incubators are related to george on
university alumni so there's a natural
bound and we have visited skydeck
berkeley we have visited a plug-and-play
both are very interested in setting up
cooperation with us and we will on
regular basis organized tour here to the
Silicon Valley and have our CEOs to have
a immersive experience of what it is
like to be in the top tier of innovation
environment and also we invite the
Silicon Valley teams to come to China
these are the team from swimming and Wes
I'm sure they're very famous here their
clients include google pinterest Airbnb
uber and Alibaba and all that so their
formal chairman mr. golden Davison read
about our some new year time and he said
to his colleague you must go to China
and offend this young folks we would
like to talk to them and establish
working relationship with them so they
met with us last November when they were
setting up Shanghai office their first
China office and we invited them to come
to our incubator our Bay West
accelerator in dreamtown this past March
so the whole team were there and they
delivered wonderful
speech about US dollar investment and
how to get an IPO in the US market and
what to do to protect your IP when you
are startup cetera et cetera and also
here are a few other events that we held
in the past so this is what we do in the
high nap by train which is the incubator
organized which is incubator operated by
one of the Georgia university alumni in
fremont and on the right side this is
the founder and still the chairman of
qualcomm in the past shanghai california
innovation forum so funny he was on the
same panel with him and they have you
know interesting conversation and so
here just some of the events that we did
and as I said we organized by week book
raiding parties so we did two books by
far we did from 0 to 1 and we did the
hardest about Hardison I love this one
better I think it's like a working man
you who for all the younger CEOs for the
startups because most of the time you
are struggling and you you just the may
be the only secret source to success is
just you just don't give up and on the
right side here are part of our
portfolio they are in different area as
you can see there are in education their
gaming their news social networking
hardware online to offline business
which is pretty hot in China right now
and there's even cartoon and third party
service and of course ecommerce which is
huge in the city of Hangzhou and here
are our very good relationships with the
media well as I remember during our
courses from MIT from 2012 2014 the
professor's from SLO management school
saying that there are five element
in a start-up environment the
entrepreneurs themselves there's
University there's government there's
big corporation for a city like hangzhou
it could be Alibaba and then there's
venture capital there's money but I
think in an environment like China
there's also the sixth element which is
a media media actually has a lot of
usage and a lot of power for example if
you are start a company media especially
the major media like you know China
Daily or whatever CDT way they report
your story it could be um like it could
be a proof from the authority at least
your employees parents would be happy
they would they would say that you know
my daughter or my son not fooling around
with you it could be some kind of
credential trust me we had a lot of help
from CCTV and all those big newspapers
especially in the first five years away
we began they rarely turn into real
others but they do help the team to get
a stronger confidence about themselves
or they do help them to convince their
families that they're not fooling around
so that part is important and also right
now there are TechCrunch equivalent in
China there are 36 their tech know there
are other technology media this
technology media usually come with their
own incubation work some even as
thinking of setting up their own angel
phones so if you have good relationships
with them meaning that you would have
opportunity to more media exposure and
they will sometimes even help you to get
some major clients or even help you to
get some funding which is crucial to
startups and I myself is also a judge in
the reality TV show about
entrepreneurship believe it or not we
have that in China as well just like
your shark tank or a princess and all
lessons we have that in CCTV to it's
called we are heroes so each TV show
there are three entrepreneurs and
we'll come here and they will do their
presentation and talk about their
product and their life and they will
take all the challenges that come from
judges like me and by end of a show the
judges will decide whether they want to
invest or not yeah it's good
entertainment okay I think that's about
it okay great thank you very thank you
so how do you see yourself dividing your
time as you go forward are you going to
work more on get these are you going to
work more on the incubator what's going
to happen with you oh well actually
right now I am more on the incubator and
the endo investment I actually that was
my I would say that was my full-time job
since 2011 but at the same time I am a
spouse of a entrepreneur so I
volunteered to help him when I can for
example I did the campus recruitment for
gershon last November so I led a team of
four people and we went to three cities
and seven universities and we collected
over 1,000 resumes and we recruit 40
people out of them so that's what I do
and mr. phone you didn't pay me money
for doing that but still I do that I
don't think well for me I consider for
both of us it's a very natural and
healthy synergy because he is the
founder CEO of his company and I work on
my end or phone and my incubator there
is this natural bound and we help each
other's business in a very healthy way
for the incubator can you tell us
anything about the kind of conditions
you're giving the companies will you
always take an equity stake no not
always i think well on the on the
regular basis we just choose our
attendance when they apply so usually
we're looking for a team less than 10
people we're looking for really small
team really early stage team and if if
we like them and they like us you can
just move in because the government
provides the real SD for us for free
within the three years
so provide this to them for free we
don't want to make any money out of
renting and usually we will give them
the incubation time of 12 months but it
could be shorter or longer than that and
in the meantime we will observe them we
will accept expect to invest some of
them if they're really good and they
want to take us take our money and I
think that is where the incubator or the
incubation can make money because you
cannot charge too high rent from the
startups and they're now doing that and
I think the only way to earn some money
is to invest some really good startups
and to make benefit out of the share and
yeah maybe one more question yeah one
more for me is the space getting really
crowded in China I mean are there lots
of incubation yes how there's a lot of
yeah and especially we we drop by we
drop by the we work space next to
Berkeley yesterday and I think the thing
is that the government are facing a lot
of challenges in terms of you know young
people especially college graduates
cannot get good jobs or cannot get hired
at all there are six millions of the
graduating every year and also the real
estate market in China is not doing so
well right now so people need a new
measure to invest so I think the
government is putting a lot of emphasis
on you know encouraging everybody to go
out there to either become an
entrepreneur also become a host of this
kind of co-working space and incubator
and accelerator and blah blah but I
still think that being an entrepreneur
are working in the entrepreneur world
are only suitable for the fewer people
it's not everybody can just go out there
and do the startup even the people who
have the guts to do that most of them
will fail so yeah the answer is that
it's going to be crowded but it's not
our business we just do what we do and
we want to fully utilize what the
government are providing at this time
even if some day the government is not
promoting this
it is doing right now I still consider
it is the worst while sin to do because
when we first started about 10 years ago
nobody was encouraging us to become a
student entrepreneur at that time my
moms think I was doing something up to
no good and especially i married my
working partner about several years
later but last no last month at the
beginning of this mouse i took my
daughter and i went to my hometown for
small made a holiday and my mom and my
dad said the first time to me like over
the decade the first time to me that we
think what you did 10 years ago you know
by becoming an entrepreneur was a pretty
cool move and yeah and they're saying
that you know you know because the the
civil servants will be called the civil
service people for working for the
government the civil servants all the
people who work for the state-owned
company they're not doing so well right
now yeah and they were very honest and
they said we thought you up to no good
will you first started and but gradually
we think that you make the right choice
and you really like what you do and we
are happy for you yeah and it's just
like that well like a couple of
questions government the government
parents approval after 10 years yes yes
but I was literally late I just read a
few times in a wheelchair Chinese
facebook yeah when impressed about
handle carbon a little by JP Ava can
keep in one meeting given to the people
in all create a company yeah yeah yeah
that's me yeah yeah there were no yes oh
well they were just actually it's not 1
million yen I heard like the highest
number is probably web million dollars
Wow yeah my million dollars but not in
the term of dollars but just that amount
of money in RMB but it's not like that
you just walk over there to the officers
say hey come
give me money the government are very
enthusiastic about bringing the overseer
attorneys to the city of Hangzhou
because it is still believed that these
guys hold the power of the highest
technology you know the full
understanding about what the market
economy is like so how new government is
very enthusiastic in helping and
bringing more of the overseer attorneys
especially people with Doctor degree
from really good university they want to
have that kind of people so if they come
back and they set up their own company
they're all sorts of criteria that you
have to meet but if you meet all those
criteria they will give you money and
also they will give you not free but
they will give you a very low interest
loan if you want to buy a house which is
very expensively handle they can give
you a very low interest nearly
no-interest loan to help you and your
employees to buy housing so I think that
is very considerate and that gentleman
in the back so I apologize and we can
designate you're gonna try and make it
but she's obviously not here oh wellz
going to ask specifically as you talked
about the customer service issue yep so
what's wandering from an HR standpoint
how did you handle that I mean I'm sure
you had employees that you kind of
didn't get with your culture be nice to
customers oh you bigger than lasted I'll
if they didn't get it
and you toss them right away correct oh
well I see you know a lot of them a lot
of my friends in the start of World a
lot about entrepreneurs themselves say
hey I really like your company culture
and you know can we learn from you and
build something as cool all fifty
percent as cool as that but what I think
is that the company culture is actually
the founder him or herself or at least
the core team because every day your
employee come to the office and they
will look at you and they will look at
how you work and how your interactive
with people I mean apart from the
incentive structures and you know all
the do's and don'ts that you will have
for your employee how we treat customers
is like most of my experience even
though I've worked with the Chinese
company has actually bins from ebay and
I'll follow yes has been already it's
some of the worst customer service I've
ever well I sit there any things I hit
probably out of over a hundred contacts
yeah everybody yeah well well I would
say you know luckily for us it's um it's
relatively small ember because we are
not a B to C or C to C Company like
Alibaba or like Amazon that we have if
you see we have like 500 we have 500,000
customers which are the developer of the
apps right but the bigger ones other
ones that we really frequently you know
interact with because most of the
smaller ones they just get our website
and the register as a user if they have
problem they call us all they send us
emails are they which had already that
are out there there's going to be more
all the time they specifically you can
focus on on that one area of customer
service and sales that's something
that's actually really a weakness even
here in Silicon yeah yeah yeah that is
that is so true of the major I will not
do it quick oh I just have seen this
right so it can be something that
allowed him to stand out a lot more than
a lot of the rest of the accelerator God
yeah well I would say the number one the
number one job all the most importance
in that CEO should do is sell sell sell
a CEO should be the top salesman when he
meets up with his potential business
partner hey selling his products and
when he meets with investor he's selling
his dreams right and when he quit he's
working with his team he's also selling
the big future that you know we should
all go there and you know people should
work hard yeah I I totally agree with
the part that startups founders or the
core team should learn more about sales
and marketing because most of them are
young people you know Lexi so that they
just come fresh out of the oven and they
don't know much about the society and
the real business were so they need
lessons for that actually we are
organizing lessons we're organizing
talks and speeches and we are inviting
some of the more senior CEOs to come to
talk sometimes even one on one with our
CEOs in the incubator or in our
portfolio so yeah that is very good
advice so actually I think that that may
be the session today oh it's oh thank
you it's uh yeah this kind of customer
services are absolutely critical part of
execution yeah all right and if you
really want to be successful you execute
and Jen you all have executed in a great
way I mean really delighted you would
come in and share some of your thoughts
with us today everybody would you join
me in giving a round of applause
you